i mean there's an exciting
longing to um visit
earth-like planets elsewhere so what's
the
closest uh earth-like planet you think
is worth visiting and how how hard is it
wow it is very hard i mean our nearest
call it earth mass planet it's orbiting
a star very different from our own sun
an m dwarf star
a small red star proxima centauri
it's over four light years away and we
can't travel at the speed of light
we can't even try i mean it would take
tens of thousands of years to get there
with conventional methods so you know
the movies like
multi-generational yeah this movie
passenger have you seen that movie
passenger it's about a big spaceship
that
is traveling to another planet and
everyone's hibernating i won't give you
the spoiler alert because one person
wakes up and then it's kind of a problem
okay got it
but yeah the multi-generational ships i
mean
when you think about where we're headed
as a species
maybe we don't send people maybe we end
up sending
raw biological materials and
instructions to print out
humans it sounds kind of far-fetched but
already we're
printing like liver cells in the lab and
beating heart cells
we're starting to reconstruct body parts
i mean the thing is it is so hard to get
to another planet
that this thought of printing humans or
printing life forms actually could be
easier
yeah that's somehow so sad
to think to think of the idea that we
would launch a successful
spaceship that has multi-generational
like
non-human life and it's going to reach
other intelligent life and by the time
they figure out where it came from
human civilization would be extinct wow
yeah that is really
that's great that's so that's one you th
there's a there's a tempting thing to
think about what are the possible
trajectories so
uh you know elon keeps talking about
multi-uh
planetary us becoming multi-planetary
species
i mean sure mars is a part of that but
like the dream is to really expand
outside the solar system
and it's it's not clear just like as you
said
like what the actual scientific
engineering steps that are required
to take it seems like so daunting
so daunting so like this the smart thing
seems to be
to do the most achievable near
daunting task even if there doesn't seem
to be a commercial application
you